ya des choses positives et des choses
qu'ils sont moins je vais commencer par
le verre à moitié plein c'était les
choses positives et d'abord des
entrepreneurs qui ont du dynamisme qui
ont envie d'investir qui a envie de
créer de la richesse de la prospérité
des emplois des chiffres qui sont
notamment sur le touriste plutôt bon des
infrastructures qui se développe
j'ai vu que l'aéroport est à + 9 % de
trafic depuis le début de l'année donc
ça c'est les signaux positifs mais il ya
des choses compliquées il ya bien sûr la
situation française globalement avec des
impôts qui sont trop élevés pour les
ménages comme pour les entreprises mais
aussi les particularités de la
martinique avec l'insularité qui
évidemment créer des surcoûts mais un
problème majeur qui a émergé qui celui
des délais de paiement qui est commun
malheureusement à d'autres départements
d'outre-mer il est totalement normal que
un entrepreneur en particulier une pme
doivent attendre un an deux ans trois
ans pour être payé c'est inacceptable
et d'ailleurs si on faisait des travaux
chez soi et qu'on disait aux plombiers
ou amenuisé je te paierai dans trois ans
ça marcherait pas donc là c'est
absolument inacceptable c'est une
situation qui semble-t-il dure depuis
des années et qui s'est aggravée dans
ces dernières années et c'est une des
choses que je vais essayer de porter en
métropole auprès de bercy et qu'on ne
peut plus continuer comme ça l'est de la
métropole est ce qu'il ya des dossiers
mise à part celui ci que vous tenez à
faire remonter en parle du à l'échelle
nationale mais aussi à l'échelle
européenne
alors ça c'est le dossier principal
après il ya la complexité au tour du ch
et 2 3 de mer qui est un sujet complexe
avec les parturientes et lamartine de ce
point de vue là et là aussi je porterai
ce dossier mais alors la vie chère est
là
des raisons un objectif puisqu'il ya
forcément il ya l'octroi de mer puisse
le nom géographique
donc il faut c'est à dire ne pas accuser
la distribution d'être responsables de
cette situation mais bien sûr c'est un
problème de pouvoir d'achat
et là ça a des conséquences sur la vie
économique mais moi je voudrais insister
sur une chose il ya du potentiel
en martinique du potentiel de long terme
à cause de la situation géographique qui
est à la fois un handicap mais aussi un
avantage notamment je pense que si les
entrepreneurs n'était été traités
correctement notamment par les communes
en termes de les paiements il pourrait
aller chercher des marchés ailleurs
notamment dans les caraïbes
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'ils fassent créer
de l'emploi ici c'est aussi retenir les
jeunes de martinique
j'ai été alerté sur le problème de
l'exil de jeunes martiniquais qui
partent faire leurs études à l'étranger
ou en métropole ce qui est très bien
mais qu'ils ne reviennent pas travailler
sur le territoire et ça c'est un
problème mon avis très très important la
seule manière de régler ce problème là
c'est d'avoir des entreprises attractif
compétitive qui puisse exporter dans
l'arc caribéen et la suite justement des
matières grises ça peut être aussi un
dossier vous pouvez oui mais tout se
tient c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
revenir les gens de force d'une certaine
manière il faut que les entreprises car
viennent soit attractif pour qu'elle
soit active il faut qu'elle ait des
marges qu'elles soient payés en temps et
en heure qu'elle puisse se offrir des
job intéressant et donc tous à part
effectivement des conditions économiques
sur le plan fiscal
moi je défendrai le statut fiscal des
entreprises d'outre-mer énormément
d'instabilité dans ce pays à l'autre
toujours débat de telle ou telle niche
fiscale mais je crois que l'important
c'est de garder une un contexte fiscal
qui soit stable